de l'argentine contestée par les
brésiliens à rio
le reportage de martine laroche-joubert
raymond barre à l'écouté des pyrénées
atlantiques
invité de cartes sur table à 20h35 liban
l'enfer de la lutte des clans un
reportage de gérard ce bagne pour la
première fois karajan au piano courant
m2 en prélude au grand échiquier
monsieur bonsoir ce sera donc argentine
pays bas dans trois jours sur cette même
chaîne à cette même heure vous pourrez
en effet assister au choc des chocs la
finale du mundial dimanche 20h la
qualification de la hollande nous la
connaissions hier soir à la fin de ce
journal
en revanche qu'il a fallu attendre
beaucoup plus longtemps pour connaître
son adversaire
on a longtemps cru que ce serait le
brésil facile vainqueur de la pologne
3-1 car alors l'argentine avait besoin
de quatre buts d'écart avec le pérou
pour parvenir en finale et bien les
argentins ont réussi leur pari dans des
conditions que l'on veut bien sûr
contesté mais nous ne le ferons qu'après
d'avoir épluché le dossier c'est-à-dire
les six buts encaissés par le malheureux
quiroga le gardien de but péruvien
d'origine argentine
il aura fallu vingt longues minutes
avant que kampess surface de la
rougeanne libère son équipe et
l'argentine tout entière
revoici l'instant où l'argentine a
commencé à espérer qu'un ps effacement
tôt 1-0
43e minute corner tête de tarantini de 0
l'argentine je prends ta y croire 49e
minute pour under green comme facebook
et capes 3 0 l'argentine se bat en
finale
revoici la leçon il amortit de la
poitrine de câm tu as lookée et campait
salle accompli 50e minute larosace entre
passarella le deuxième poteau pour
loquet 4 à 0 l'argentine est en finale
on sent la sueur en revoyant ce but elle
ce n'est pas fini
66e minute kampess lens ortiz qui prend
la défense de vitesse
ousmane marque le cinquième un cinquième
but sur lequel la dépense péruvienne
paraît assez patient
62e minute gorriti se fait subtiliser le
ballon pas la rosa qui centre pour look
et 6 à 0 l'argentine jouera donc la
finale contre la hollande
dommage que les péruviens n'ai pas joué
avec la détermination dont ils ont fait
preuve
en d'autres circonstances
oui je n'ai pas besoin de vous dire que
cette écrasante victoire des argentins a
provoqué dans tout le pays une véritable
explosion de joie ça dit bien sûr il
fallait marquer ce sivu les argentins
bénéficier d'un avantage ils
connaissaient le résultat du match
brésil pologne un gros deux matelots du
par parenthèse avec beaucoup de ballons
sur les bois que dans les bois vous
voyez ici nous sommes en seconde mi
temps un centre de toninho que nous
croyons au ralenti et ce tir de même que
ça sur le coteau roberto reprend et
marque 2 1 pour le brésil à ce qu'au
moins quatre minutes plus tard dit
retrait ou centre en retrait gilles le
face à roberto qui tire lui aussi sur le
poteau gilles repent tir sur la barre et
une minute plus tard la 62e minute
nouveau tir de dire que vous allez voir
sur le poteau reprise de roberto ce
point pour le brésil
voilà donc 3 1 pour le brésil face à la
pologne mais cela ne suffisait pas et
vous imaginez que are you à 2000
kilomètres plus haut et bien l'ambiance
était tout à fait différente ce n'était
que gémissements complaintes et surtout
accusations tout cela n'est que
magouille dit-on aujourd'hui au brésil
martine laroche-joubert et là bas nous
la réunion tout de suite hier en deux
heures le brésil est passé de l'euphorie
au désespoir après le match contre la
pologne
le carnaval a commencé dans les rues
samba pétards feux d'artifice tout le
monde défiler et personne ne pensait
sérieusement à regarder la télé et le
match argentine
héroux et puis petit à petit les
clameurs se sont tues
l'une après l'autre des bruits courent
et l'argentine serait en train de
marquer but sur but alors ils sont tous
vides a reflué vers les postes de
télévision placé au coin des rues et
dans un silence total
les visages se sont transformées il y en
a des qui pleurait au coin des rues ont
replié les drapeaux ont replié les
tambours et jamais un pays
monsieur autant insulter hier soir que
le pérou alors ce matin la presse
brésilienne est extrêmement violente
le brésil gagne mais ne l'emportent pas
robot veulent le pérou sans honneur ici
à l'interview de coutinho l'entraîneur
brésilien
c'est une honte le pérou a libre et le
jeu aux argentins les joueurs péruviens
ne pourront plus entrer dans un terrain
de foot et entendre la tête haute
l'hymne national des scènes hot modérés
ont été apportés par la fédération
brésilienne de foot qui loue le bon jeu
des argentins et lui shell hidalgo
interviewé hier soir après le match
argentine pérou et lui déclare que
personne n'accepte qu'une équipe perdre
parce que l'autre était la plus forte
alors monsieur soudas vous êtes le
journaliste sportif quelles sont vos
réactions après avoir vu le match et lui
la presse ce matin
le pe a fait de cette coupe de monde
la coupe de la honte de ce set
un événement sportive jusqu'à hier soir
d'après eux cette transe hors baie dont
deux spectacles qui accourent dave
ulliott j'assiste le monde du football
couvert de honte mais pourquoi parce que
aux joueurs de vous ont pratiquement
laissé les invente un marquis combien de
boue il voulait catégorique je crois que
dans l'intérêt spécial d'éliminer le
brésil
je ne vois pas de raisons historiques
pourraient expliquer ça je ne vois que
des raisons financières pour expliquer
une en résultats à mon avis surprenant
et très très très bizarre et les
péruviens unies'' rien c'est pourquoi
nous nous garderons de toute accusation
précise tout est possible fatigue ou
autre et voyez-vous en france aussi
cette affaire a eu des retombées bien
fâcheuse dans un petit village de l'ain
une mère de cinq enfants a tué son mari
et la suite d'une scène de ménage
le mari voulait suivre le mundial à
télévision et son épouse nous venons en
maintenant à la politique d'abord voyage
de raymond barre haut béarn et au pays
basque le premier ministre a passé la
journée à l'ecoute du département des
pyrénées atlantiques en dialoguant avec
les élus et les responsables sur place 2
envoyé spécial spéciaux pardon du
journal d'antenne de bernard pradines au
est d'abord patricia chartier le voyage
de travail de raymond barre dans les
pyrénées atlantiques a donc commencé ce
matin à pau au parlement de navarre le
premier ministre a eu un premier
entretien avec les responsables du
département sur les problèmes
économiques et sociaux
le maire socialiste de la ville andré
labarrère assister à cette réunion qui a
été suivie dans la matinée d'une
rencontre avec les syndicats
les discussions ont porté sur les
difficultés de la région liés par
exemple au gisement de lacq et à la
production aéronautique
si le premier ministre a annoncé une
réforme du système d'indemnisation pour
les agriculteurs il a bien fait
comprendre qu'il n'était pas venu pour
faire du saupoudrage de crédit il faut
at-il dit écarter les coeurs des
pleureurs en début d'après midi raymond
barre a présidé à orthez une réunion de
travail avec le conseil municipal
finalement par sa présence ici le
premier ministre a montré que j'ai
loigne mans avec paris devait être
comblé et par le style de son voyage que
l'avenir d'un département dépend des en
grande partie de l'imagination de ses
responsables a dit non pour la suite du
voyage est bien dans une vingtaine de
minutes le premier ministre a est ici
dans ce studio à bayonne
l'invité de jean-pierre elkabbach et
duhamel pour répondre dans cartes sur
table le plus directement possible leurs
questions sur la politique générale de
la france la panne la journée a été
celle d'un premier ministre au chant
monsieur bart a inauguré une usine
implantée en pleine campagne à ce parent
dans le pays basque au milieu des
groupes de chanteurs battre après la
conférence de presse de quelques minutes
le premier ministre a rappelé que la
france aurait encore des difficultés
économiques mais qu'elle avait des
atouts pour les surmonter
on parle beaucoup trop dit monsieur bart
d'entreprise qui marche mal ou sacs
terrains et adapté de sel guy novés
progresse comme leroy somer lusinchi
venait d'inaugurer ou boncolac une
entreprise voisine
tout au long de la journée monsieur bart
a parlé de la nécessité de lutter contre
ce qu'il appelle la morosité
comment de quelle façon eh bien ce sera
une des questions qui lui fera poser
dans cette émission cartes sur pas dans
une vingtaine de minutes donc rendez
vous tout à l'heure tout de suite passé
journal pour cartes sur table municipale
partielle désistement du pc au second
tour à aix-en-provence de la en faveur
de la liste socialiste bien sûr georges
marchais à france inter ce matin le
parti communiste sortira renforcée de la
grande discussion qui a eu lieu en son
sein le reste de la politique c'est
aussi la réunion des maires socialistes
des grandes villes de france à rennes au
tour de françois mitterrand et une
journée d'étude organisée par l'udf avec
pour thème la lutte contre les
inégalités d'abord rennes françois
mitterrand au congrès des maires
socialistes aujourd'hui à rennes ce
serait une erreur historique grave de
croire que les dirigeants communistes
hésite entre l'union de la gauche et le
repli sur soi
il y a ajouté le premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste une troisième hypothèse
qui peut être la première l'union des
communistes avec la droite une formule
appliquée à la france du compromis
historique
les communistes obligent leurs alliés à
s'aligner sur leurs positions il ne faut
pas accepter cela a dit monsieur
mitterrand ni créer une
agilité socialiste face à celle des
communistes démontré que l'udf est un
parti politique à part entière capable
de proposer des réformes tel était le
but de la réunion de ce jour mesures
pour l'emploi impôt sur la fortune
solidarité envers les moins favorisés
furent les thèmes traités souvent sur un
mois de critiques ce qui a fait dire à
jean jacques servan schreiber qu'on
avait perdu trop de temps monsieur
lecanu est pour sa part s'est réjoui de
voir que toutes les impatiences était le
signe de la tendance démocrate de l'udf
tendance qui devrait stimuler l'ardeur
réformatrice du gouvernement
nous entendons dans notre dernier
journal françois mitterrand et jean
lequel devait détailler davantage lors
de manifestations sur le canal qui par
ailleurs n'a pas jugé très grave les
petites querelles au sein du dff le
centriste bernard stasi avait trouvé que
le parti républicain en faisait un peu
trop et que certaines de ses attitudes
été dominatrice jacques blanc elle lui
avait répliqué que le p r n'avaient
aucune prétention hégémonique sur l'udf
le dossier social maintenant avec les
suites de l'affairé boussac en prélude à
la grève générale de tous les
établissements du groupe demain les
ouvriers d'epinal et paris ont manifesté
aujourd'hui se met dans la capitale
ce n'était pas tout à fait une
manifestation comme les autres ce n'est
pas devant le domicile de marcel boussac
que le personnel est venu manifester cet
après midi sous la pluie c'est devant le
siège central du crédit lyonnais
et c'est en cela que ce rassemblement
n'était pas une manifestation ordinaire
chez boussac pensez bien que c'est le
crédit lyonnais qui avec un dmp est à la
tête du pool bancaire qui supporte les
énormes dettes
un groupe lorsque marcel boussac ces
jours derniers a fait savoir qu'il était
prêt à brader l'essentiel de ses biens
propres
ce sont les banquiers qui ont fait
remarquer hypothèque en main que le roi
du coton proposait quelque chose qui ne
lui appartenait plus on en est là
aujourd'hui et pour la première fois un
personnels menacés à court circuiter
l'entreprise et ses dirigeants pour
frapper directement à la porte les
banques
reste à savoir si c'est la bonne porte
car il est peu probable que ces banques
surtout les grandes nationaliser
modifient leurs positions sans une
incitation de l'état aux arsenaux
maintenant alors que le mouvement de
grève se poursuit dans une centaine
d'établissements andré bergeron réclame
l'ouverture immédiate et sans préalable
de négociations dans les chantiers
navals dubigeon normandie annoncé une
réduction de
r à la ciotat les syndicats vont
organiser prochainement une journée
ville morte chez moulinex le conflit
paraît dans l'impasse une septième usine
est entrée dans le mouvement
le groupe reprend 11 la régie renault
enfin le travail a partiellement repris
à l'atelier des grandes presse de flins
avec du personnel non gréviste et avec
la maîtrise
la mission du médiateur a pris fin
aujourd'hui sans que soit annoncé une
reprise des négociations
c'est donc dans ce climat social pour le
moins troublée que s'ouvrira demain la
seconde grande négociation entre le
patronat et les syndicats
c'est ici dans cette salle du cn peuple
s'ouvrira demain la seconde grande
négociation patronat syndicats
on y parlera de l'aménagement du temps
de travail sur une proposition du
patronat modifier la loi des 40 heures
pour adopter un système de budget de
temps annuel géré selon les besoins
d'entreprises et les souhaits des
salariés
parallèlement à ces négociations on
constate que le climat social dans le
pays se durcit et que les conflits des
bouches de plus en plus difficilement
sur des compromis
actuellement plus de 200 mille
travailleurs sont engagés dans des
conflits d'entreprise 150 de ces
conflits portent sur l'emploi 250 sur le
pouvoir d'achat et 77 sur les conditions
de travail
c'est que en réalité les négociations
qui se déroulent au niveau national et
dans les branches professionnelles se
joue à deux degrés autour d'une table
comme celle ci et puis sur le terrain et
on note que certains grands conflits
démarre en même temps que les
négociations dans les branches
professionnelles exemple de renault
alors que l'on discute des bas salaires
dans la métallurgie exemple les ptt en
grève hier alors que des négociations
sont en cours dans la fonction publique
ou bien encore la sncf qui sera
partiellement grève ce week-end
l'objectif est d'obtenir sur le terrain
des rapports de force qui permettent de
faire pression sur les négociateurs
l'objectif dyer avait été clairement
annoncée par les syndicats et il
explique cette épreuve de force
exceptionnelle à la veille des vacances
deux sondages que nous avons relevé
d'abord celui de la sofres dans le
figaro qui paraîtra demain 58% des
français sont encore favorables à la
peine de mort contre 31% qui sont
hostiles
jeudi encore car dans la précédente
enquête il y a deux ans 72% des
personnes interrogées et est pour la
peine de mort
et puis cette enquête ifop de vsd que je
ne détaille pas mais qui prouve que les
français face aux vacances
préfère-t-il rester moins longtemps mais
ne pas se priver et que leurs dépenses
représentent en moyenne un mois de
revenus j'en viens maintenant à la
politique étrangère avec un discours
attendu ce soir celui du président
sartis chef de l'état libanais s'il
s'est décidé à parler alors qu'il ne le
fait pratiquement jamais c'est que la
situation est grave au liban une fois de
plus le pays s'entredéchirent surtout
chez les chrétiens et les phalangistes
une semaine après l'assassinât de tony
frangié le fils d'un prédécesseur de
monsieur sartis à la présence d'un
public une mer bleue un soleil
éblouissant un port de plaisance avec
ses remparts historique construit par
les croisés c'est le liban
traditionnelle du tourisme et des
vacances quelques libanais essaie de
s'en persuader
mais pour quelques heures seulement pas
car la réalité du liban est tout autre
la véritable image du liban
c'est celle de la violence de la
vengeance et de la vendetta qui se
prépare à seulement 50 km de là à la
guerre civile à la lutte des chrétiens
contre les palestiniens et les
progressistes s'ajoutent même temps les
luttes intestines des maronites à scorta
ces femmes en noir qui viennent briller
dans cette église construite au xvième
siècle n'oublient pas qu'ils s'y sont
enterrés depuis seulement quelques jours
le fils et la famille du seigneur des
lieux
l'ancien président souleiman franjieh
même si en privé la famille frangié ne
souhaite pas la vendetta on n'oublie pas
que souleiman franjieh en 1957 n'a pas
hésité à tuer à coups de revolver
le député curé d'un village voisin en
pleine messe il avait une aide de 100 à
payer était devenu l'un de ses ennemis
politiques
sans faire preuve de faiblesse et perdre
la face
les habitants de scorta ne peuvent
accepter l'affront à l'entrée du village
la maison de souleiman franjieh les
délégations de villageois d'hommes
politiques se succèdent pour présenter
leurs condoléances et aussi leur soutien
politique
car derrière cet affrontement entre les
deux grandes familles chrétiennes les
franges et jemaiel il y à une lutte
d'influencé politique le parti des
phalanges de djemaï elle a essayé de
s'implanter sur les terres des fringues
juillet je crois que ce le point de
divergence entre le président agit en
tant que chef de famille et les partis
politiques
c'est essentiellement l'expansion que
les partis politiques ont fait durant la
guerre dans la région même de président
fin juillet et il faudrait pas aller
rechercher ailleurs
j'espère que les sages de ce gâteau et
des habitants de certains pourront
convaincre le clan fringer nier qu'il
est temps aujourd'hui de mettre terme à
tous les agissements irresponsables qui
ont eu lieu jusqu'à maintenant mais de
votre pays le prix du sang a une grande
importance et on dit que la manière de
se ranger pour la famille france j'ai ce
serait d'attaquer la famille gemayel
personne ne les en empêche france dans
le fief des jemaiel on s'attend à des
représailles
les mariages par exemple sont célébrés
sous protection militaire
surtout pour les cadres du parti comme
ce mariage celui d'un chef de milice
derrière cette nouvelle vendetta qui
vient de naître dans la montagne
libanaise réapparaissent les dissensions
oublier pendant les deux ans de la
guerre civile
chez les maronites du liban un
affrontement plus graves entre chrétiens
ne pourrait laisser insensible syriens
et israéliens dont l'affluence est de
plus en plus forte dans le pays encore
d'autres texas le gouvernement américain
est d'accord pour que le supersonique se
pose à dallas ce sera un prolongement
des lignes paris washington et londres
et washington
tout cela au moment où la construction
de concorde est officiellement arrêté
l'inculpation de cinq dirigeants de
coeur assistance a service privé
d'urgence à la disposition des
cardiaques les dirigeants ont été
inculpés de publicité mensongère
le reste de l'actualité maintenant
quelques flashs a commencé par le procès
à moscou 2-2 juifs soviétiques qui
avaient manifesté pour obtenir un visa
en israël
entrée interdite aux journalistes et à
la famille des accusés pour le procès
des deux juifs soviétiques qui réclamait
le droit d'émigrer l'accusation trouble
de l'ordre public
ils avaient accroché une pancarte à leur
balcon nous voulons rejoindre nos
enfants en israël voilà sept ans qu'on
attend les visas de sortie
le verdict 5 ans d'assignation à
résidence
quartiers bouclés et mesures de sécurité
exceptionnelles autour de la prison de
turin le verdict dans le procès des
brigades rouges est attendu ce soir
renato curcio leur chef pourrait être
condamné à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité
première démonstration publique du
missile de croisière aux états unis cet
engin diabolique présente toutes les
qualités de l'avion à réaction de la
bombe et du missile
il vole à 50 mètres de hauteur et
échappent aux radars
on peut aussi l'équipe et d'une tête
nucléaire téléguidé il obéit
parfaitement à son maître
c'est la grande peur des soviétiques le
camion musée volé mardi à marseille
retrouvé sur la route d'aix-en-provence
sur les treize toiles de maîtres qu'il
transportait une seule restait à bord
une vue de marseille 2 2 mètres 40 sur 1
mètre 50
signée du peintre provençal loubon trop
encombrante pour les voleurs qui
pourtant étaient des professionnels mais
la dernière fois que vous étiez venu
lambres m comme désormais d'ailleurs
tous les jeudis vous ne nous aviez parlé
que du mauvais temps et bien non
seulement ça continue mais il est même
question de record mais oui imaginez que
samedi dernier on a battu des records de
froid pour un 17 juin puisque la
température n'a pas dépassé 13 degrés de
à paris et 12 degrés cet achat retrait
auxerre alors ce week end et bien on va
sans doute pas battre des records de
froid quand même c'est plutôt la pluie
diva l'usiné est en plein tournée de
bassins plus basse que d'habitude
par exemple cet après midi il faisait de
13° 14 degrés sur la manche à 14h égard
plus de 22 degrés à nice et je vous le
dis c'est surtout le ciel sombre et puis
la pluie qui vont nous ennuyer pourquoi
qu'est-ce qui se passe eh bien il ya une
zone de nuages chargés de pluie qui
tourne autour des îles britanniques et
qui est en train de traverser la france
est derrière cette zone il ya de l'air
qui vient d'atlantique nord qui est
froid et humide qui est instable et bien
il va s'installer vendredi et samedi sur
toute la phase concrète mans d'abord
pour vendredi c'est à dire pour demain
et bien vendredi le temps va être
nuageux avec des averses sur à peu près
l'ensemble du pays le matin le soir
c'est dire à peu près au moment du
départ en week end et bien les pluies
vont surtout se localiser sur le suit
d'un bilan des orages la méditerranée
les alpes
et puis le nord-est dans le reste du
pays mais il y aura quelques éclaircies
mais des éclaircies assez courte
malheureusement très courte et des
ventes en baisse sur le web
attention encore plaisanciers pour
samedi maintenant samedi bien ce temps
instable sur ce mélange de mauvais temps
avec un petit peu d'éclaircies va
généraliser sur tout le pays il y aura
surtout des pluies
et sur la manche et puis de l'autre côté
de la corse
ozalp encore des classes une petite note
d'optimisme quand même pour terminer il
y aura un désir les rssi un peu plus
longue
un peu plus belle sur le sud surtout sol
languedoc et puis un peu après sur la
provence pour dimanche si vous voulez
parler mais une tendance on veut pas
s'engager pourquoi parce que
scientifiquement bien la météo prévoit
deux jours à l'avancé alors bien sûr il
ya la persistance et à dire qu' il peut
pas faire très mauvais samedi puis
soudainement merveilleux dimanche
disons qu'on peut pas encore l'idée
d'intervenir beaucoup de choses au frac
il vaudra mieux en parler et on en
reparle il avait un corps tu es à
longchamp la combine aux gagnantes et le
11 le 4 le 7 et le cese vous allez
découvrir ça et vous le découvrez sur
votre écran dans un ordre conforme aux
lois y ait un peu moins de 35 mille
francs pour 5 francs et dans un ordre
différent un peu plus de 2000
ce soir encore nombreuses sont au rendez
vous que vous donne la rédaction
d'antenne 2 je suis le temps d'une page
de publicité ses cartes sur table donc
indirecte de bayonne raymond barre face
à jean pierre elkabbach et alain duhamel
vers 23h40 dernier créneau réservé à la
formation le journal présenté par pierre
alain mais d'ores et déjà je voudrais
vous donner un autre rendez vous avec la
musique celui ci samedi à 20h30 jacques
chancel consacrera son grand échiquier à
herbert von karajan et au philharmonique
de berlin
les répétitions de cette émission
exceptionnelle retransmise également sur
france musique en stéréo ont déjà
commencé regarder écouter voir pour être
parmi les meilleurs musiciens du monde
on en est pas moins sportifs et le
philharmonique de berlin profité hier
soir de chaque pause dans les
répétitions du grand échiquier
poursuivre le mundial pendant ce temps
jacques chancel faisait le point sur les
missions avec herbert von karajan
non
bonjour m
la télévision pour vous c'est quelque
chose que vous aimez depuis très
longtemps ça a été un précurseur
justement vous avez été des premières
retransmettre des émissions lyrique je
crois oui il ya maintenant quinze ans
qu'on fait des cellules seulement
maintenant on a trouvé avec tous les
moyens qu'on a pris dans les studios à
rembrandt a transféré sa maintenant sur
l'air
dans son bain
scène de la télévision des gens life
dumont
à
pour
chez lui il joue très souvent vu bien
lorsqu'il vers la maison parfois il
adore se mettre au piano c'est super il
envie de l'amour vu comme ça le diamant
moi je lui avais proposé j'avais dit
qu'on sera en direct de la philharmonie
de berlin et me dit non je voudrais que
ce se passe exactement comme dans les
conditions du grand échiquier ses dires
c'est à paris et en plus je voudrais
montrer combien j'aime la france il a
très peu d'hommes et de gens qui me
connaissent réellement je pense que ce
second kg qui va permettre à des
milliers de gens des millions de gens de
découvrir un quatrième qui méconnaissent
pas plus loin
il
à